and he was like Awareness on what
seizures look like is extremely
important because of Hollywood everyone
thinks you fall to the ground and start
spazzing out
some people said I think it's like an
absent or absence seizure absent seizure
where you just freeze and lock up and a
lot of people were tweeting that this is
may be what it was apparently he said
that he got light-headed and he was fine
and then went on to have like a normal
meeting afterwards or whatever but I
think what we're seeing here is
you know we talked a whole lot about
aliens in law and morality
our political leaders
they keep winning no matter what no
matter what because our culture is dead
because this country will just walk into
a booth and rubber stamp D or R without
a thought because it is a dead culture
so against the mind so they vote for
Pelosi they vote for Mitch McConnell
they vote for people who should have
retired 30 years ago and I don't see it
changing unless there's a hard fall